my name is Sean me as sheriff media
rising GA I just said let's get it idiot
rising is the most historic best music
label in the world bro but deeper than
that I think we're a family of creators
that certainly music is a big part of it
but we aim to just tell stories or in
whatever medium that just make people
happy and inspire people we started as
more of a media company doing video
everything from Japanese mixology to
crazy art to certainly music and what
ended up happening is because we're so
small some of our music stuff just
popped off I always worked in music like
even since I was really young I was just
a musical starting events I was like
doing marketing for for artists and like
brands in music right so I was always
like in it but in my late 20s I just
like decided to go to New York and came
over here with my suitcase and I just
never I never went back home dude I
struggled to be honest in New York Bros
I didn't have [ __ ] I would just stay in
the Bronx and work all day every day bro
just seeing the Bronx in like I would go
to Dunkin Donuts and that's where I
would get Wi-Fi cuz I would want to work
all day at my house and that's where ATI
rising was built I mean I just put
together a PowerPoint you know and had
some nice pictures and now as I look
we're gonna make the Vice for Asian
culture and people are like yeah I like
them I really didn't care what business
he was in I knew he was just the guy
that was gonna be a winner you know
somebody's gonna really make something
happen what he was was an idea Shawn is
an idea into himself
so anyone like that you get behind
and if I were still at Interscope at
that point I would have grabbed them for
Interscope easily I just think he's a
guy we would feel and soul that can
deliver on his promise and he gets he
knows how important the artists are and
he's got an idea that I believe he can
complete bro growing up in the Bay Area
made me I lived in like the most perfect
neighborhood you have all types of kids
Latin Latin American Mexicans African
Americans white Asian and we're all just
playing together you go outside and
you're able to get inspired by taste
different foods go to go to my homies
house and listen to different music I
just fell in love with music at a very
early age and I started to figure out
how to consume good music and try to
find it through my friends and that was
like my pastime is just going to the
record shop and the perfect like
American experience of what it was in
the 80s and 90s
and when I was 13 I really wanted to go
to America because that's kind of when I
started exploring comedy and I remember
just like being on Twitter and just like
learning the American sense of humor it
was really confusing at first because it
was just like so different from the
Indonesian sense of humor I think
working with Shawn has been amazing
because he's a manager but he's also a
lot of other things he's an A&R he's
like creative and like you could tell he
like thinks a lot about creative stuff
and like he has a really good vision I
love it when artists kind of do things
that are not really caring about what's
trending or like what people like I
don't know I feel like not enough people
do that nowadays
we've never collaborated with anybody
but we've worked with 88 rising now I
think that when you're out here on the
Internet streets and you're and you're
putting up videos and stuff like it's
just important to have someone and I
think that 88 Rising is that same energy
but in a different direction
so they have this collective music this
thing that's timeless but then it's like
very much of the time I think it has
been an upward battle entire time trying
to get recognized and trying to gain
credibility in this space but I feel
like people are recognizing like where
80 is that so I think more than hasn't
know just like constant like upward
trend we've already done the internet
[ __ ] well you could only go viral so
many times right now we're putting out
the [ __ ] that we feel is better than
everything but like we can't rely on
dude like some internet phenomenon
happening every time we have to you know
people have to support us any arising is
the constant daily evolution a year ago
or six months now we're in is way
different than we are today we just do
[ __ ] some some of it work some of a
dozen but like the stuff that works it
like really takes us to the next level
and all these different energies are
happening around us and that's gonna
spark a lot of passion passion sparks
people trying stuff and the more people
that try there's gonna be like you know
the diamonds in the rough right the
people that change the course of history
this is my American spirit
[Music]
[Applause]